next question today david vaccination is
going
really well in the united states
vaccines for everyone who wants them
how much credit does trump get for
vaccination
listen he gets very little he gets very
little and what i mean is the following
um moderna and pfizer
are companies that existed in the united
states long before trump and they were
on the forefront of medical science
johnson and johnson same thing
uh astrazeneca you know different
vaccine same thing so certainly
trump gets no credit whatsoever for the
fact that some of the usual players
were the first to get moving on vaccines
that would be used
trump gets zero credit for that okay
second question
who thought up the vaccines well you
know the truth is that back in january
the virus was sequenced when it comes to
the pfizer vaccine
turkish immigrants to germany are the
ones who actually put together the
the building blocks of this vaccine it
was ultimately developed and produced by
pfizer trump certainly gets no credit
for that now what did trump do well
operation warp speed operation warp
speed
what trump did is what any any
any president short of a true
sort of genocidal psychopath who wants
to prevent
vaccine development would have done
which is what
uh trump made funds available uh
for companies that wanted to participate
in operation warp speed the big
manufacturers did not participate in
operation warp speed from a development
standpoint
and then yes the government agreed to
pre-purchase
a whole bunch of vaccines so that
production could start even before we
knew
which candidate vaccine is going to
eventually be the one that's used
you can give trump credit for that if
you want any
sane president would do that okay so
when we give him credit for that what
we're saying is trump didn't go out of
his way
to make it more difficult to get these
vaccines produced and the reason you
have to do this and the reason this is
so commonly done
when you are developing a medication for
an urgent
health situation is if you wait until
approval to start manufacturing
you're behind so on spec as we call it
you start manufacturing vaccines before
they are actually approved so that if
they're approved you have a whole bunch
of them ready to go
trump allowed that to happen he didn't
get in the way of that he can get credit
for that he acted like a normal person
on that
on distribution he gets essentially no
credit distribution was a disaster when
joe biden came in
we were vaccinating 800 000 people a day
there were vaccines that were
unaccounted for
there was no plan turned over to joe
biden it was an absolute
complete and total mess so how much
credit does trump get
he gets very little he by downplaying
the virus reduced interest in people
getting the vaccine
the distribution was essentially
non-existent trump got vaccinated in
january didn't even go public with that
until march at which point two more
months
of building anti-vaccine sentiment had
been allowed to fester and ferment
so trump gets extraordinarily little
credit
if you disagree with me let me know